I have a headache and Google says it's
brain cancer do I have brain cancer hey
mom so I'm having people over for the
first time this weekend and I really
need your mac and cheese recipe so what
exactly are stocks how do I get them do
I need them what should I make for the
main dish who sings that Motown song
with the lyrics I don't know something
about heaven charm there's an arm in
there I just get all your recipes just
yet to send them all to me no well not
by mail just email them to me can I get
your Netflix password so how much is too
much to pay for braids Hulu so how
exactly do you fold a fitted sheet cuz
it's not looking quite right
HBO it won't cost you anything how many
times can you wash his ziplock bag mommy
you need to talk to supper
I know she's my sister I love her but
she is acting crazy how often am I
supposed to on my scout when is cousin
Shawn's birthday
can you do my taxes for me what about
uncle Antonio Oh could you apologize to
him for it yes thank you and I promise I
will stop cussing do we have Native
American on our family really what tribe
hey just wanted to tell you that I love
you and I miss you and I'm glad that I
can come to you for advice yeah I'm
making sure I get my vitamins yeah
mm-hmm I'm getting enough sleep mom I'm
an adult
[Music]